Morgan is in Boise Idaho hi Morgan how
are you I'm doing well have yourself
days better than I deserve what's up so
my wife and I got ourselves into about
$250,000 in debt and what I stood alone
all of it yeah all of it
who's that we have there's the doctor or
lawyer my wife will be shortly I hope
she'll have her doctorate in
pharmacology a doctorate and she's gonna
have a PhD and finally so what do you do
with that that's not that's not a
pharmacist
it is the pharmacist that's actually
what's required now really yeah okay so
she's gonna be a pharmacist and she's
and what do you do I work in
manufacturing making one about 55 grand
a year and this 250,000 is all hers
yeah I'm sorry we actually moved across
the country and before we used to deal
finances together but I've been doing
all the finances for last four years and
and I recently came across you I listen
to a few of your books and I'm just
trying to figure out how I mean she has
a lot on her plate but she just doesn't
want to be involved with finances at all
I'm trying to get her on board and I'm
not really sure how to do that well when
when does she graduate in May and passes
boards after that in order to get a job
right yeah okay so she's gonna be
concentrating all that between now and
August
I mean she's completely absorbed in
hitting this goal okay yeah but what I
would do is just begin to plant the seed
that at the time that that happens we
are going to start handling things
together okay
I'm not your daddy I'm your husband
and you are too smart to not be involved
emotionally in making the decisions of
cleaning up this 250,000 dollar mess so
we are going to have to make some very
tough decisions together I am NOT going
to make them by myself you and I are
going to make them you get a pass
through your boards
after that it's grown-up time and the
two of us are gonna sit down together
and we are going to make decisions about
our future and about cleaning up this
mess and how deeply we're going to
sacrifice to get that to happen I'm not
going to drag you kicking and screaming
through two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in debt I have no desire to be
married to a woman where I'm her daddy
now you can be a little kinder and less
blunt than that but that's the message
yes I say how do you say that in a more
kind and gentle way well I mean here's
the thing the number one cause of
divorce in North America days of money
fights and money problems you've got
money problems you are going to get sick
and tired of carrying this intellectual
genius that you're married to and making
all the hard emotional decisions for her
you're gonna get really tired of it
you're probably already a little tired
of it but you're just too nice to be as
blunt and brash as I am but but by the
time 10 years from now rolls around
you're gonna be sick of it and you're
gonna meet resistance every time you try
to create a sacrifice to pay this dadgum
disastrous mess off because she's
probably not gonna make a hundred 100 a
half so your household incomes gonna be
like 200 and it's gonna take you guys
three years of living on like your
college students on beans and rice to
clean this mess up this is a 200 it's a
ridiculously large debt and it's gonna
take a while so anyway the way you say
that is just say number number one honey
that number one calls the divorce of
North America today's money fight some
money problems I've been studying this
guy he's making a lot of sense I get it
that you're all-in until your boards are
passed I'm with you on that
at that point you and I for the sake of
the quality of our relationship have got
to work on this together I'm gonna need
your help your bright to be good I'm
sorry I'm sorry what do you think it'll
make sense for maybe after that period
after she's graduated for us to do
financial piece together to get us on
the same page
sure lots of people do that okay but
she's got to want to do that there's a
conversation that gets her in the pet on
the path before you just announced hey
we're going to this class together I
mean you could do that sometimes that
works but usually it's more like it's
very important and that we work together
on this I'm gonna need your help I don't
mind doing the details but I do mind
carrying the weight of all the decisions
and you not having visibility and making
part of the decisions so let's walk
together and make sure that the quality
of our marriage a good way to do that
might be then we go through this class
that might be what you do but that yeah
she's she has you know the way you get
through something like a ph.d program or
you know you know become an MD or
whatever you know at that level is you
have to have a singular focus and you
know what I'm saying is is that as a
couple you're gonna have to change your
singular focus from that once she passes
our boards to cleaning up the mess that
was created by getting that degree so
hey thanks for the call